i was down at my good friend olivia
omar's event it's called model
volleyball it's in miami every year
and i came across a lovely girl i did an
interview with and her name was victoria
fresh v-e-s-h
bachelor p-s-c v-e-s-c-e but spelled
pronounced vesh like french the country
way to say it i mean in italy you say
vegeta but i thought it was vegeta yeah
i mean you can do the italian i met the
lovely victoria and i was asking women
all about what they're looking for in a
man how important is money to a man
would you ever date a broke guy like if
he was hot like these types of questions
so let's play a little snippet of that
and then on the other side we'll have a
conversation so how important is a man's
income let's make sure the volume works
it has to be that's the same or more as
mine as long as you're not homeless
homeless guys need not apply i think
more importantly what is my income i
need a man to match my level of success
i'm not going to say money doesn't
matter because it definitely does i'm
like a family woman and i feel like if
you want to have a family you have to
like have some type of income i have my
own money but money is this close to
oxygen you really need it to breathe
cool
uh by the way uh leave we're doing super
chats at the end of the show let's let's
keep that going and we want to get your
comments but uh the lovely victoria
um you know most women said it was very
important the money but you said quote
unquote
more important than a man's income is
what's my own income right i need a man
to match my level of success
so i'll ask you this again how important
is a man's income to you
i mean it's important in terms of who
will be like my partner because it's
going to be hard if a man has a lesser
income than me because i
talk going back to masculine and
feminine energy those lines become
blurred and then at the same time like i
want to have a partnership like i don't
want to have to take care of someone
like and they probably don't have to
take care of me all the time i'm more of
like okay let's have a fruitful
partnership and like and grow together
and that's what my mom and dad did and
that's like what i saw growing up so
you're following your parents exam yes
and they had what what type of business
together
um they did a lot of like international
real estate real estate my mom was a
boss babe like my dad is still the boss
so
my mom unfortunately passed away last
year but uh they were together for uh
almost 40 years and so they had a really
healthy happy marriage they traveled the
world together set a good example they
said a good example
yeah did they do real estate together
yeah they did they did my mom had her
own company at first and then
and then they came together so nice
yeah i'm just following what i grew was
like raised and
sometimes it doesn't work though
nine times out of ten when i see what my
friends they like rely on a man or a man
relies on a woman too much and
that's when everything just
falls apart you're saying nine times out
of ten when one of your friends relies
on a man what happens it falls apart why
are they married well i've had some
friends who've almost been married so
engaged or
very like lived together and
they relied on the man so much they lost
their own identity what we're talking
about they lost their own like income
and they didn't like focus on themselves
and
now i have like a friend who's kind of
like out cold in the middle of hawaii
like trying to rebuild herself because
she relied on a man so much damn well
she's in hawaii i mean hawaii is not a
bad yeah i'm out called the of hawaii
it's not a bad place to be but that's
like one example of like so many of my
friends like
melissa uh how important is a man's
income to you
uh to me it's extremely important i i
married a broke guy and i'll never do
that again uh and i was the breadwinner
in the relationship
um you know and then um after that you
know i've dated successful men after
that so and you mentioned this earlier
that and you said that you're the
more the masculine boss of that
relationship in in my marriage and that
in the marriage ten years ago
and that you said he felt emasculated
and that's why he cheated on you
according to what he said mind you i met
him when when i was 21
um and he was seven years older than me
okay um but you were still the boss in
that relationship and he was older yeah
wow yeah what's that what's that little
money song
yeah and i just made sure i never dated
another broker ever in my life again so
what are the disadvantages of dating the
broker
um
a lot
they can't afford to take you on
vacation they can't afford you to take
you to dinners you're paying for
everything
they can't afford you you know to buy
you a nice gift you know they can't
afford you to afford to take you to nice
hotels and
they can't afford to buy your first
house i bought the cars i bought the
houses like
you know um
so so yeah that won't happen again so
and you would not date a guy um
if he's not doing well financially just
not even gonna happen not even so that's
like red flag you might meet a guy
that's hell yeah tall good looking sexy
great that was him never again and just
travel the same way like would you want
to date a girl that's in like a horrible
financial spot and that yeah and all she
has is looks like
you're asking me what my opinion on that
yeah would you want to date a girl
that's in a horrible financial spot i've
done that what are you talking about
and that didn't work out so well not
because i needed her to get a better job
it just didn't work out but guys and
women men and women are very different
but i think it's the same like in a
general concept like you gotta
understand something ladies
men
we don't care
don't we don't care like
i'd like to differ men don't care what
your career is they don't
they want
i did this the other day
first and foremost men are want to like
what they see with their eyes okay
facts like i heard you saying this
recently actually you go on a [ __ ]
dating app right and i'm just starting
to do this i don't really do i haven't
done it for
until covered right i'm like all right
gotta give it a shot somehow and all
you're doing is yeah i like that nope i
don't i'm not like well you know she's a
lawyer and you know but that's an
initial like chemistry correct but
that's initial boom but then that's the
first thing serious okay so then second
second is what's her demeanor she's
lovely she's pleasant yeah she's cool
she's funny she's quirky she i like it
whatever all the personality stuff all
that and then third oh she happens to be
a
fill in the blank
men aren't like dude i met this girl
okay she's actually a psychiatrist
i'm like yeah i don't give a [ __ ] bro i
actually have a lot of guys who come to
me and they're like wow you graduated
law school that's so hot that you're
successful that's so hot like you have
your [ __ ] together
because you're hot victorious if you
were a busted lawyer they'd be like they
don't wanna they don't wanna go with
their looks cause then that's too
obvious yes they gotta stand out now
what i will say is i just don't think it
would work out if like she was a
financial disaster you would be like oh
great yeah if she had like a spending
problem maybe you know you could have
some issues there bingo we're talking
about like that being an interesting
long term we're not she's gonna she's a
spender and she's not and she doesn't
about it either you just hit the nail on
the head bro if she's
like
in the red pill community they use the
word compliant i'll just say sweet okay
but
if she's sweet and supportive and all
that
you'll deal with it but
if she's not bringing home the bacon and
wants to spend all your money as a guy
that's a major red flag i've dealt with
that before okay but it's different men
are more visual and women are turned on
by their ears things that guys say
being a gentleman hi may i get the door
for you oh you look lovely tonight so if
you like that clip click right here to
watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
[Music]